so watch the sagas array as we run this
line of code at this point a new
function has been added to the sagas
array and even though that function is
being referenced by a variable in the
global scope the function itself has the
blue type of scope access because it's
fundamentally a blue function that
originated inside that red function so
we've reached the big question what do
you think is going to happen when we try
to run one of these blue saga functions
that was created inside the red context
but is now being accessed from the green
context
remember the red context that it was
created in has already completed and
returned so any variables that are
referenced by this blue function from
the red context seem perhaps like they
should be unavailable so when we invoke
this sagas Sub Zero function a blue box
should appear somewhere in our diagram
based on your understanding of how these
contexts work where would you expect
that blue box to appear